y hoy en directo va como ya lo
anunciábamos vamos a Panamá allí inicio
este jueves la conferencia Our Ocean el
evento congrega a gobiernos de todo el
mundo empresarios y miembros de la
sociedad civil para pactar compromisos
que ayuden a proteger los océanos vamos
a Ciudad de Panamá con María Clara calle
enviada especial de France 24 María
Clara Cuáles fueron los grandes anuncios
de este primer día de Hour Ocean
Pues esta conferencia la lógica es
anunciar compromisos todo el tiempo por
eso este día se hicieron decenas sin
embargo uno de los más importantes fue
que Panamá Se comprometió a crear la que
será el área protegida Marina más grande
del Caribe al sexto duplicar el área
banco volcán una vez lo logre llegará a
proteger el 54% de su zona económica
exclusiva cuando la meta mundial que se
trazaron el año pasado todos los países
fue proteger el 30% Ecuador por su parte
anunció la creación de la reserva Marina
con ocho millas de línea costera y otro
de los grandes anuncios es la alianza
carbón azul que busca proteger corales y
pastos marinos pues estos absorben cinco
veces más de dióxido de carbono que los
bosques y a cambio de esa protección se
perdonarían los créditos el programa
contó con el apoyo de 4,8 millones de
dólares por parte de Reino Unido y otra
de las grandes noticias es que las
potencias incrementaron sus promesas
Estados Unidos pasó de hacer compromisos
por 2.600 millones de dólares el año
pasado a casi 6.000 millones este año y
la Unión Europea prometió 816 millones
de dólares La diferencia es porque
Estados Unidos es el creador de esta
conferencia desde 2014 María Clara
paralelamente en Nueva York la ONU
discute el tratado de altamarque En qué
consiste este pacto y qué están diciendo
del tema los expertos y los líderes que
están reunidos también en Panamá
primero hay que entender las diferencias
entre zona exclusiva económica y altamar
la primera comienza desde la costa hasta
200 millas náuticas estas pertenecen a
los gobiernos y es allí donde se
comprometen a proteger las áreas después
de eso viene el altamar donde no hay
ninguna regulación a pesar de que allí
están dos tercios de los océanos por eso
lo que está discutiendo la ONU es tan
importante Pues sería el primer tratado
internacional legalmente vinculante y no
es nada fácil pues esta es la quinta
Ronda de negociaciones luego de que en
agosto no llegaran a un acuerdo acuerdo
que ahora sí se espera el próximo 3 de
marzo aquí en Panamá la presión esa que
la ONU por fin decida este tratado y
afirman que los compromisos que aquí
hagan no tienen ningún sentido pues
ninguno de ellos sería legalmente
obligatorio Y menos si no existe el
tratado de